thomas avec l'annoncé de la prise de
parole de joe biden s'était tenue
beaucoup croyez à la fin du suspense
mais finalement le feuilleton continue
après une nouvelle nuit encore agitée
outre-atlantique et joe biden qui s'est
donc exprimé oui et toujours pas de
vainqueur on n'est plus trois jours
maintenant après le scrutin et le
dépouillement se poursuit dans un
certain nombre d'états les écarts sont
parfois très serré avec notamment le
vote par correspondance qui nécessite
plus de temps pour être comptés alors
ses dernières heures les médias
américains ont actualisé leur chiffre
assez régulièrement il apparaît
dorénavant que joe biden est en tête
dans un certain nombre d'états clé c'est
le cas par exemple en géorgie mais dans
cet état l'écart est trop serré il va
donc avoir un recomptage des voix c'est
ce qu'on a appris ce vendredi mais c'est
maintenant la pennsylvanie qui est
scrutée de près l'état natal de joe
biden où il ya également de nombreuses
mises à jour notamment dans les villes
de pittsburgh et de philadelphie
concernant le dépouillement joe biden y
est également donnée en tête et s'ils
l'emportent ils ré il récolterait 20
grands électeurs ce qui lui permettrait
d'atteindre la barre fatidique des 2 170
grands électeurs qui sont nécessaires
pour être élu président des états unis
mais vous l'aurez compris rien n'est
encore officiel on attend peut-être
l'issue du scrutin en pennsylvanie dans
le courant du week-end peut être dans la
journée de ce samedi
alors on avait appris vendredi à la mi
journée deux pas de la part de l'équipe
de campagne de joe biden que le candidat
démocrate allait prendre la parole le
soir même et à ce moment là certains
observateurs pensaient qu'il pourrait
s'agir de la proclamation de victoire de
la part du candidat démocrate mais ce ne
fut donc pas le cas en raison des
chiffres qui ne sont pas encore officiel
joe biden qui s'est toutefois dit
confiant sur l'issue du scrutin
il a appelé encore une fois ses soutiens
à la patience écoute est donc cet
extrait de son allocution c'était aux
alentours de 23 heures ce vendredi ici
aux etats-unis depuis la ville de
wilmington dans l'état du delaware
nous n'avons pas encore de déclaration
finale de victoire mais les chiffres
nous raconte une histoire claire et
convaincante
nous allons gagner cette course regardez
ce qui s'est passé depuis hier
il ya 24 heures nous étions derrière en
géorgie maintenant nous sommes devant et
nous allons gagner cet état il y à 24
heures nous étions derrière en
pennsylvanie et nous allons gagner en
pennsylvanie nous allons gagner cette
course avec une claire majorité la
nation derrière nous nous avons 74
millions de votes
je vais le répéter nous avons 74
millions de votes c'est plus qu'aucun
président n'est reçue dans l'histoire
des états unis
alors malgré ses appels à la patience
joe biden s'est déjà projetée pour ce
qui reste ce qui pourrait être son
agenda pour ses premiers jours s'il
était élu à la maison blanche avec une
priorité la lutte contre la propagation
du coronavirus 127000 cas ont été
détectés ces dernières 24 heures aux
états unis ce qui constitue un record
dans le pays
écoutez ce qu'en dit joe biden hier la
sénatrice harris et moi même nous avons
eu des réunions travers des groupes
d'experts dans le domaine de la santé
publique et la crise économique que le
pays fait face et comme vous le savez la
pandémie est en train de se répandre
encore plus aux quatre coins du pays
laissons la colère et la diabolisation
derrière nous il est temps de se réunir
en tant que nation et de guérir ce ne
sera pas facile
ma responsabilité en tant que président
sera de représenter toute la nation et
je veux que vous sachiez que je
travaillerai autant pour les gens qui
ont voté contre et pour moi le dos ou
vaughan smith joe volpe joe biden qui a
dit qu'il espérait pouvoir reprendre la
parole dans le courant du week-end cette
fois pour annoncer de manière officielle
qu'il avait remporté cette élection mais
la confusion règne encore ici car
parallèlement aux lans décompte des voix
il ya aussi les accusations du président
donald trump sur ce qu'il qualifie de
fraude des fraudes supposées donc ces
dernières heures le locataire de la
maison blanche a publié un certain
nombre de tweets concernant ce qu'ils
présentent comme des problèmes lors du
dépouillement on sait que le président
conteste la légalité d'un certain nombre
de bulles
mais aussi sur la façon dont ils sont
comptabilisés écouter j'avais une telle
avance dans tous ses états jusque tard
dans la nuit des élections pour voir
seulement cette avance disparaître
miraculeusement au fil des jours
peut-être cette avance reviendra-t-elle
au fur et à mesure de la progression de
nos procédures judiciaires joe biden ne
devrait pas revendiquer à tort la
fonction de président je pourrais
également faire cette réclamation est la
procédure judiciaire ne fait que
commencer
on ne sait donc pas si le suspense va
finalement prendre fin ce week-end car
même si certains médias pourrait
proclamer ou en tout cas annoncé la
victoire de joe biden dans les
prochaines heures on sait que donald
trump est prêt à aller sur le terrain
judiciaire pour contester le bon déroulé
des scrutins dans un certain nombre
d'états rva donc observer attentivement
l'évolution pour tout ce qui concerne ce
week-end au monde et maintenant donc
plus trois jours après la tenue de ce
scrutin
merci tom abonnés pour ce décryptage
complet en direct donc de washington